we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you know the
claims about donald trump paying someone
to take his SATs have raised questions
about my SATs take a listen to this
David
this is Dave from California yeah I have
a question Neri Trump said that the
president had somebody else take the
SATs for him right my question is David
did you take your own SATs yeah by
listen if I paid someone to take my SATs
I would have come away with a better
score it's kind of a sad it's not a sad
story but just sort of a story of like
being an immigrant family because my
family came to the United States when I
was five my parents never went through
the college admissions process in the
u.s. my mom ultimately went to graduate
school here but that's a very very
different process and that was after
that that was much later anyway and so I
didn't know anything about how do you
prepare for the SATs SAT prep materials
SAT prep classes or any of it so I had
no preparation and I just showed up and
took it and I did fine enough I got a
twelve ninety back when it was out of
1600 I believe now it's out of 2,400 but
you know I later learned about other
people who were doing prep classes they
had tutors they took the test multiple
times for me I just showed up and took
it once and that was it and it was
fortunately good enough to get me into
the University of Massachusetts in
Amherst Massachusetts even applying for
school I had was just filling out
applications I didn't understand you
know you can request an interview and
this increases your chances of getting
in there's something called a common
application I filled out individual
applications for every school even
though many of them were on the I just
had no idea but in any case yes I took
my own SATs
I also took my own GMAT when I took that
to get into grad school nothing and
again had I treated I would have gotten
myself a better score thank you oh we
have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about how the u.s.
is reportedly considering banning
tic-tock and some other Chinese media we
will talk about Texas is now ready to
resume X
Hewson's after delaying some during the
corona virus pandemic and new jersey
will now require outdoor masks outdoor
masks all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show reminder about next
Tuesday Tuesday night at 8 p.m. Eastern
we will have the 3rd ever David Pakman
show chess tournament I will be playing
last tournament in June we had 732
players I hope to do better than that
this time you can sign up now for free
for the tournament at david pakman.com
slash chess we also on the same day will
be doing a 1-day membership special
meant to dig us out of a 300 member hole
created earlier this month and you can
be notified about this membership
special very simply by getting on to our
mailing list at david pakman.com you go
to david pakman.com top right of the
website you will see a place where you
can type in your email address get on
the mailing list tuesday midday you will
get an email with a very powerful
explosive coupon code that will get
grant you an extraordinary discount off
of a membership and then hopefully that
night as a new member you'll play in our
chess tournament again which you can
register for it david pakman.com slash
chess i will see you in mere moments on
today's bonus show or otherwise tomorrow